we will now turn our attention to the
data store commit process this process
describes the consistency rules when
storing data data store has to
consistency models eventual consistency
and strong consistency let's look at
these in more detail in this use case
diagram we have three things your
application the datastore API that your
application calls and the data store
backend which performs work that your
application is not involved in when your
application wants to store an entity it
performs a put operation towards the
datastore API the data store back end
then writes this entity to a log when
the right is completed control is
returned back to your application at
this point the data store back-end has
promised a variety entity to datastore
observe however that the entity has not
been written yet it has only been
written to a log the data store back-end
now goes to work to make everything
consistent it does this by using the log
information to update the entity storage
and then it updates all the indexes so
observe that when control is returned to
your application data store may not have
done all the work required for the data
to be updated it's this good or bad well
it's good because this means that you
have less latency in your application
but the question now becomes what
happens if a query is issued that would
retrieve the data your application just
requested to put in datastore well with
eventual consistency the datastore API
will not wait for this to happen so it
only considers matching data that
already exists that is data that was
already in datastore prior to your put
call and then it returns that result
that's why it's called eventual
consistency queries will be eventually
consistent with put operations performed
towards the datastore API